Well, I believe that this is very important, since
our country is currently suffering from
constant missile attacks and various
types of different means of destruction.
border thanks to
this system I listened to it this morning
because we have no light for several
days after the recent arrival
Very inspiring I liked the parallels
and the hornet They
like all the historical parallels it gives even more
weight the
most dramatic moment there How
was the transfer of
our flag  from the soldiers, let's say, and with
thanks for the weapons provided, for the help provided, the
tears are welling up. I
really hope that they will help not
only the Ukrainians, because we have
nothing to impress anymore, but rather the
American Congress. As far as I
understand, it is very influenced by them there, that is
, their decision  can influence
further steps on the further amount of
aid,
I think it is very cor  It is true for our country
at the present time and very much. It will help to
protect our energy system and
some of our infrastructural military
facilities and civil infrastructure
because it is simply impossible to tolerate
such a furious enemy that it is impossible
to live normally even for people, especially those
near the front, closer to the front  in some
areas it is very difficult to get out and this is a
very
unusual event and we see the
support of the people and the senators in the
congress of the president and the country and we
strongly
agree with those Theses that the president
voices and we
strongly support him in that he is
trying in every way to protect the country and
to attract as many resources as possible, with
more help in order to
finally overcome our cursed enemy, I believe that
this will protect Ukraine from missile
attacks and the civilian population. Well, how it will be affected,
I cannot say for sure. Well, I think that it
will be very good news.
a little bit like this this morning yes well
impression
Well so powerful powerful How are you?  there were even ants in the
congress
[music].